it's a great of a pleasure to be with
you it's a great also opportunity to
talk to you because advertising
presidency it's good to have also you
have use and establish this dialogue
which was missing the last few years
from what I understand so our aim is to
fold with this meeting first of all to
connect the European Bloch sphere with
the Cyprus presidency and secondly to
connect our bloggers with the European
blog as we have two representatives from
Cyprus and I would like to welcome them
warmly to this meeting citizen
participation is at the heart of the
European Union that's at the heart of
the European politics in this regard we
are looking forward to they're having a
fruitful dialogue with the bloggers with
the representatives of the blogosphere
and this is as I said very important for
the rotating presidency to know the
views to hear the views to hear the
expectations of all European
stakeholders thank you very much the
Bloch sphere of cyprus's is nothing else
than a mirror of the Cypriot society
when we highly said before that is very
difficult for the young people to
express themselves and the political
views is because we are not used to it
but things are changing changing are
changing fast in online the median
cypresses is not usually known as
doesn't have the capacity of the ability
to be a watchdog on the official
rhetoric it usually ends up mirroring
the official rhetoric and not
challenging enough so the the internet
as a new forum as a new kind of platform
for people to express themselves is
still I think at the moment being
grouped within the general way that
people see the media there was a
conclusion that the even when they open
a union or the European institution with
the opium authorities used the new
technologies they missed the advantage
of these technologies they use it in a
in a very traditional ways as you sang
amends here before just
just put in the communique and the press
release but don't use it don't using the
possibility of all the interactive
communication with the public opinion so
they don't they miss this this Ram
opportunity and the last conclusion and
very worrying given that the in the
panel there were very young people is
that the European you know Union cannot
survive in this in this way that the
European Union has to adapt to the 21st
century or will disappear because his is
working with methods and ways coming
from the 20 Century from 60 years ago
and they are not fixed anymore for for
these times citizens are the most
important part of blogging and that's
why they need to be taken more into
account the European Union sometimes is
really very distant from from the public
opinion from the people and on the other
hand that the Internet can help to to
correct things and perhaps to get once
again in touch with the people many
bloggers and guys said it would be good
if the presidency could build some kind
of a platform for bloggers for example
if on the internet home page you could
reproduce some important information
provided by social media by tweets by
blogs and so on or if you could create
something like press clippings for
social media the motto of zerzura
opinion in foreign policy was to speak
with one more maybe it is it is better
to have more voice that just one voice
it is 22 to 12 Communications on all
sources also affected is not only to
have a communication come from research
to to social media but could use the
delegation in the European Union they
are on the ground
to communicate locally to use social
media to have a specially to to commit
get some more information on the ground
this meeting was more useful to us
perhaps in a way than it was to you it
provided an opportunity to begin better
understanding the reality of the
European blogosphere and be able to
start laying the foundations for the
establishment of the better
collaboration for the benefit of the
European society